[Musik]
Kiew und 10 Regionen im Land unter
Beschuss wieder hat das russische
Militär mit Kampfdrohnen angegriffen das
Ziel die Zerstörung der
Energieversorgung auch Wohnhäuser wurden
stark beschädigt Menschen verletzt
russlands Präsident Putin ist heute ins
Nachbarland Belarus gereist mit dem
dortigen Machthaber Lukaschenko will er
die strategische Partnerschaft ausbauen
was immer das bedeutet
willkommen zum zdf-spezial je kälter es
wird je mehr Infrastruktur zerbombt wird
desto dramatischer wird die Lage für die
Menschen in der Ukraine
ein Kriegswinter immer wieder ohne
fließend Wasser Strom und Heizung das
ist die harte Wirklichkeit für Millionen
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine wie Sie mit
dieser Not umgehen wie sie durchhalten
und versuchen durchzukommen das
schildert uns Anne Brühl auch mit einem
tröstlichen Moment am orthodoxen
Nikolaustag
die U-Bahn ist der sicherste Ort in
Harke deshalb ist auch der Nikolaus
hierhergekommen
Spiele und Geschenke für die Kinder es
ist eine Normalität mitten im Krieg
ich wünsche dass der Krieg bald zu Ende
geht und alle friedlich leben und für
mich will ich eine Barbie
es ist schwer weil es Explosionen gibt
bei uns haben gestern ein bisschen die
Wände gewackelt
das Kinderhilfswerk der Vereinten
Nationen hat die Aktion auf die Beine
gestellt mit vielen ukrainischen
freiwilligen wenigstens an diesem Tag an
diesem Ort dürfen Kinder Kinder sein
für Kinder ist das eine sehr gute
Möglichkeit um wieder unter Menschen zu
sein denn nach all der Zeit in der sie
zu Hause waren oder sich in den Kellern
versteckt haben ist es für sie ein
kleines Fest ein kleines Wunder
mehrmals am Tag auch in der Nacht heulen
in hakifft die Sirenen Luftalarm
immer wieder gibt es raketeneinschläge
hier wird ein Verteilzentrum der Post
getroffen fast zehn Monate Krieg haben
Spuren hinterlassen in der Stadt
zerstörte und beschädigte Häuser und die
Temperatur sind von Tag zu Tag weiter
die Weihnachtsbeleuchtung hängt noch vom
letzten Jahr in den Straßen
eingeschaltet wird sie nicht dafür ist
der Strom zu knapp
mit Blick auf das nahe Weihnachtsfest
haben die meisten nur einen Wunsch
in erster Linie den Sieg und das dann
alle glücklich sind
der Krieg soll bald Enten und Genosse
Antichrist Putin soll zur Hölle fahren
dem Land wünsche ich Frieden und mir
einen Schutzengel
Frieden für die Ukraine das bleibt wohl
vorerst ein frommer Weihnachtswunsch
ja das zu sehen ist bedrückend und
beeindruckend zugleich an der Bröhl in
harkev sie sind nicht zum ersten Mal
seit Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine was hat
sich denn am meisten verändert
als ich im Sommer hier in der Ukraine
war da hat der Krieg vor allen Dingen
sich auf Orte und Ortschaften in der
Nähe der frontbezogen und dem Rest des
Landes konnte man fast so den Eindruck
gewinnen dass die Menschen so eine Art
Auszeit von Krieg nehmen ein bisschen
durchschnaufen das hat sich jetzt hier
komplett verändert und das hat vor allen
Dingen mit den gezielten Angriffen auf
die Infrastruktur zu tun die ist ja seit
Oktober gibt und das betrifft wirklich
jeden hier in diesem Land die gesamte
Zivilbevölkerung jeder muss jederzeit
damit rechnen dass es kein Strom kein
Wasser keine Heizung gibt und das ist
hart bei diesen Minusgraden die hier
herrschen haben Sie denn den Eindruck
stellen wir immer
in den Städten stellen wir fest wird das
relativ schnell repariert am Freitag gab
es hier Angriffe auf rakev am Samstag
hat der Strom schon wieder funktioniert
in den Dörfern sieht das aber ganz
anders aus da sind ganze Ortschaften
total abgeschnitten da sind die Menschen
früher überhaupt an darüber im Kopf zu
haben haben sie denn den Eindruck dass
die anhaltenden russischen Angriffe die
Menschen entmutigen oder abstumpfen
lassen
na das Gefühl was hier vor allen Dingen
überwiegt ist dieses Entsetzen darüber
mit welcher Härte Russland diesen Krieg
führt Russland das vermeintlich einstige
Bruder Volk und deswegen ist die
Entschlossenheit bei vielen Ukrainern
auch wirklich sehr hoch eine Frau die
wir in ihrer kalten Wohnung getroffen
haben hat uns gesagt natürlich habe ich
Angst vor dem Winter aber wenn ich jetzt
aufgebe dann hat Putin gewonnen und das
darf nicht passieren und äh mit vielen
dem wir sprechen da klingt das ähnlich
und das ist nicht unbedingt hurra
Patriotismus man muss sich allerdings
auch fragen welche andere Alternative
haben viele Menschen die müssen einfach
bleiben in ihren Häusern und ihren Orten
die können gar nicht weg was ist denn an
Hilfe von außen am dringendsten
notwendig um das Leid der
Zivilbevölkerung zu lindern
Generatoren warme Kleidung vor allen
Dingen aber eben auch Geld denn vieles
gibt es hier in der Ukraine also
Baumaterialien oder Lebensmittel etwa
dass das findet man aber den Menschen
fehlt das Geld viele haben den Job
verloren durch den Krieg die Männer sind
an der Front die Inflation ist sehr hoch
in diesem Land wir haben gestern in
einem Dorf in der Region Harke gedreht
das war bis September von den Russen
besetzt haben da eine Frau getroffen die
mit ihrer sehr alten Hochbetagten Mutter
zusammen lebt und die sagt wir leben von
der sehr kleinen Rente meiner Mutter die
Heizung bei uns funktioniert eigentlich
wir haben aber kein Geld um den Strom zu
bezahlen aber was man sagen muss die
Hilfsorganisation sind vor Ort die
internationalen vor allen Dingen mit
vielen ukrainischen Freiwilligen die
Hilfe und das Geld auch aus Deutschland
das kommt an hier vor Ort vielen Dank
für diese Schilderungen und auch für
ihren Einsatz dort an
wie sehr die Bevölkerung leidet haben
wir gerade gesehen und gehört aber wie
geht es den ukrainischen Soldaten und
Soldatinnen an der Front wie sieht ihr
Leben dort aus unter Beschuss in diesem
Kriegswinter Bobby Cherry an berichtet
die Hände dieses ukrainischen Soldaten
geschwollen von der Kälte und der
Feuchtigkeit
auf -15° sollen die Temperaturen hier in
der Nacht schon gefallen sein in einem
Wald im Donbass an der Front sie heben
Gräben aus so gut es geht der Boden ist
kalt aber halbwegs trocken
hier gibt es Sand das Wasser ist
versickert so muss man nicht durch den
Matsch warten
die Gräben bieten Schutz vor der Kälte
und vor gegnerischen Angriffen im Wald
im Winter müssen Sie mit dem arbeiten
was da ist
im Notfall versteckst du dich wo immer
Du ein Loch findest
hier wäre es okay es ist nicht abgedeckt
aber es würde dich retten
plötzlich Beschuss die Ukrainer feuern
zurück
der Krieg geht weiter auch im Winter
sie haben sich darauf eingestellt auch
hier in der Nähe von bachmut ebenfalls
in der Ostukraine
das Wasser in den Plastikflaschen ist
gefroren aber auch dafür gibt es eine
Lösung
während es auf dem selbstgebauten Herd
auftaut wird geschossen
sie machen weiter trotz widriger
Umstände
wir sind hier auf unserem Land und wir
müssen es verteidigen es ist hart aber
es ist notwendig
es ist dieser Einstellung die die
Soldaten hier trägt
durch den Kampf und die Kälte
ja ein harter Kriegswinter also an der
Front und wie ist die militärische Lage
einzuschätzen darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit Christian Mölling von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik
guten Abend nach Berlin hallo guten
Abend es heißt immer Russland könne
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen ist das so
oder machen sich die Ukraine und der
Westen da was vor
nein wir sehen ja seit zehn Monaten das
Russland immer weniger militärische
Optionen hat das beschießen der zivilen
Infrastruktur ist ja eigentlich eine
Ausdruck davon dass man keine
militärischen Optionen tatsächlich mehr
hat um an der Front und auf den auf dem
Gefechtsfeld nach vorne zu kommen sodass
man sich andere Mittel sucht um hier
Erfolge zu erzielen Erfolge die auch
wichtig sind zu Hause für Putin weil er
eben militärisch nichts vorzuweisen hat
in dieser Nacht hat es wieder heftige
Angriffe gegeben offenbar mit iranischen
Drohnen da zeichnet sich so eine Art
militärpartnerschaft ab zwischen den
Regimen in Moskau und Teheran wie
gefährlich ist das
natürlich schafft Moskau es jetzt
erstmal durch die Lieferung aus dem Iran
die die Angriffe auf die zivile
Infrastruktur vorzusetzen das ändert
aber an der Lage im Gefechtsfeld eben
selber nichts da sieht es so aus als ob
die Ukraine einfach durch die Lieferung
aus dem Westen für das wintermaterial im
Vorteil ist und dazu kommt auch dass
insbesondere die USA jetzt ihre
Produktion an Munition hochfahren und
damit ab 2023 verstärkt die Ukraine
unterstützen können wir sehen insgesamt
dass ich zwar die Lage durch den Winter
verändert das aber der Krieg deswegen
nicht aufhören wird
zurzeit trifft Putin den weißrussischen
Diktator Lukaschenko das Militär von
Belarus sei einsatzbereit hieß es heute
rechnen Sie mit einem Angriff von
Belarus auf die Ukraine das ist zurzeit
noch relativ unwahrscheinlich auch
deswegen weil die Belle russischen
Streitkräfte auf der einen Seite kein
Interesse haben oder Lukaschenka kein
Interesse hat in diesem Krieg
hineingezogen zu werden sie auch
schlecht ausgerüstet sind und ähm
schlecht ausgebildet sind von daher ist
das zurzeit möglicherweise eher eine Art
von Propaganda Maschine die hier anläuft
von daher geht es glaube ich eher darum
darauf zu gucken was im Osten und im
Süden der Ukraine abläuft
nichtsdestotrotz gilt wir haben viele
Chancen vertan in den letzten Monaten
als Westen wir hätten die Ukraine schon
längst soweit bringen können dass sie
diesen Krieg gewinnt die Frage ist und
die Hoffnung ist dass Deutschland und
Europa in 2023 mehr tun werden
Kriege Enden ja mit Sieger und besiegten
oder eben am Verhandlungstisch auf
beides deutet gerade nichts hin wie lang
wird dieser Krieg noch dauern also der
Verhandlungstisch und das Gefechtsfeld
schließen sich nicht aus sondern im
Gegenteil sie sie begegnen sich
gegenseitig diese Bedingungen sich
gegenseitig das heißt also erst wenn auf
dem Gefechtsfeld stillstand ist ist es
überhaupt möglich zu verhandeln und ist
auf der politischen Ebene so dass
eigentlich die Verhandlungsmasse durch
Putin immer weiter verringert worden ist
er besteht da drauf dass die Gebiete die
ja offiziell oder aus seiner Sicht
annektiert hat dass sie ihm gehören und
dass die letztendlich abgegeben werden
müssen das ist von vorher schon etwas
interessant weil die Gebiete ja gar
nicht kontrolliert sondern er verliert
sie ständig weiter ist also in einer
sehr schlechten politischen Situation
wenn es zu einem Friedensschluss Thema
dann würde er zu Hause erklären müssen
was er gewonnen hat und das sehe nach
sehr sehr wenig aus seiner Sicht aus das
heißt für ihn ist ein schlechter Krieg
besser als ein schlechter Frieden
das war die Einschätzung des
Militärexperten Christian Mölling vielen
Dank für das Gespräch schöne Grüße nach
Mainz
und wenn sie den Menschen in der Ukraine
helfen wollen spenden Sie bitte an das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine IBAN de65
400-100 400 600 alle Infos auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im zdf-text auf
Seite 890
was von Moskau anfangs verharmlosend
militärische spezialoperation genannt
wurde und in wenigen Tagen erledigt sein
sollte ist ein abnutzungskrieg geworden
der mit fast allen Mitteln geführt wird
Krankenhäuser Wohngebiete Energieanlagen
werden beschossen um den Willen der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer zu brechen
das sind Kriegsverbrechen man muss es so
klar sagen
das war unser zdf-spezial vielen Dank
für Ihr Interesse hier geht es gleich
weiter mit dem wieso Spezial Patient
Deutschland Gesundheit im Notbetrieb auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]